[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
controversial cambo fossil fuel giant
shell withdraws its plans to develop the
north sea oil field
how climate intelligence can help
increase resilience in cities at risk
from the impacts of climate to crisis
and the orphaned otters separated from
their mums during bad weather now being
released back into the wild
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions now shell has
scrapped plans to develop the cambo oil
field in the north sea that's after the
project faced sustained criticism from
environmental groups the oil giant had a
30 stake in the site but now says that
the economic case for investment isn't
strong enough as our scotland
correspondent james matthews reports
it was a day for big energy news on the
chromatin for
here at the port of neg they're building
the uk's largest wind tower factory
nicola sturgeon came to announce it
thank you but what off the other big
story in the energy world cambo shell
and the company's pool out scotland's
first minister had said cambo should not
go ahead giving your opposition to the
development of the campbell oil field do
you welcome shells withdrawal well
shell's made a commercial decision i
don't know what that will mean for the
future of campbell the
consenting for campbell's of course is
not my decision it's the uk government's
decision my view is absolutely anchored
in the determination to
transition those who currently work in
oil and gas into other green clean jobs
for the future
shell said that after comprehensive
screening of the campbell field near
shetland it concluded the economic case
for investment isn't strong enough at
this time
environmental campaigners have welcomed
the withdrawal of the 30 percent
stakeholder with some claiming it marks
a beginning of the end for new oil and
gas projects in the north sea while
there is doubt over cambo it's by no
means dead yet sicker point is the
company that owns the majority 70 stake
in the project
it says it remains confident of cambo
and will continue to engage with the uk
government about future development
the oil and gas industry at large has
watched developments with concern behind
all of this the need for in the gas
remains in the uk
and we can help provide that in a much
more sound
climate-focused way than many other
countries can do
our own gas production is as third
damaging as anyone else's so by using
home resources we can really make an
awful lot of good for the environment
and also benefit the economy in doing so
campbell remains a work in progress but
it looks like a development more
difficult today than it did yesterday
james matthews sky news at the porch of
nick
well we'll be discussing that later in
the program but let's take a look at
some of the day's other climate news now
and the uk government has ramped up
plans to clamp down on illegal
deforestation in its supply chains a
consultation announced today will look
at new measures that could make it
illegal for larger businesses to use
commodities whose production is
associated with large-scale
deforestation supply of products such as
beef cocoa soy coffee and palm oil could
be affected
meanwhile the uk's supply chain crisis
isn't just taking a toll on the
availability of products it's affecting
the environment as well carbon emissions
at major seaports have reached their
highest level since 2008 that's
according to a new report from
singapore's nan yang technological
university backlogs and delays are
causing prolonged turnaround times
during which ships continue to emit
harmful gases
british airways will become the first
airline in the world to use sustainable
aviation fuel produced on a commercial
scale in the uk the fuel will be made
from recycled cooking oils greases and
other household waste and could be in
use as early as 2022. the airline has
committed to powering 10 of its flights
with sustainable fuel by 2030 now that
would cut carbon emissions by around 80
percent compared to flying with
traditional jet fuel
the real beauty of sustainable aviation
fuels is that they're a drop-in
replacement for fossil-based ejection so
they can be used in aircraft now without
the need for any changes and passengers
won't notice any difference just like
flying on normal fuel and the difference
is that the maximum blend at the moment
that we can put in or sustainable
aviation fuel is a maximum of 50
and depending on the fuel type it may be
a little less than that but for now
we're just talking about kind of putting
this into the supply network so that all
of our flights can have a little bit of
sustainable aviation fuel powering them
and the singer billy eylish is this
year's recipient of the honorary
german sustainability award for her
commitment to climate protection she'll
receive the award virtually via the
german astronaut matthias mara live from
the international space station billy
elish publicly advocates for climate
protection and sustainability to her
millions of followers worldwide
and two otters who were separated from
their mothers during storms when they
were little cubs are starting life in a
new home buddy and holly were rescued by
the rspca in the spring of 2020 and
after 15 months of rehabilitation the
now adult otters are ready for release
back into the wild with the river ooze
selected as their new habitat
now sky news understands that boris
johnson has pledged to use special legal
powers to persuade electric vehicle
manufacturer vivian to establish a
european base here in britain our city
editor mark hyman has more
this is an interesting development in
the race to persuade electric vehicle
makers to establish a major
manufacturing presence in the uk now i
understand that boris johnson has
written to the chief executive of rivian
one of the world's biggest electric van
makers
to encourage him to open a major new
factory at a site near bristol now in
this letter the prime minister says that
the government would use a special
development order which is a a form of
planning law to make planning decisions
for your project and ancillary
infrastructure now and in the long term
this would be using a uk law the prime
minister goes on that's rarely used and
reflects the importance of your projects
in the uk and mr johnson also said in
this letter details of which have been
shared with me uh that he has made it
his personal priority to see rivie and
choose the uk as its european home and
this comes as rivien considers other
sites elsewhere in europe for this major
manufacturing site but of course it
comes at the time when the
automotive industry globally is under
pressure to electrify its production uh
capabilities and as we've seen from
data
on a frequent basis in recent years
electric car sales are rising both in
absolute terms but also as a share of
overall car sales and data from new
automotives electric car count that was
published this week showed that november
november was the highest
month on record for the market share of
electric vehicles in the uk so it would
obviously be a major coup for uh the
johnson government
if ribbian did choose to locate its new
manufacturing site in the uk equally it
would be a blow if rivien decides to go
elsewhere in europe
now we are living in increasingly
vulnerable cities that's as climate
change is pushing urban areas into
climate zones that their infrastructure
just isn't designed for well that is the
warning from the climate intelligence
company serviced which has been looking
at how our cities could be at risk in
the future well let's have a look at
what they found over the next 30 years
75
of the world's major cities are expected
to shift into different climate regimes
or that means london for example will
feel more like barcelona by 2050. well
heavy rainfall is projected to increase
in northern europe making severe city
flooding more likely for example in
finland's capital of helsinki which is
at particular risk due to winter melting
and its coastal location and as global
temperatures continue to rise cities
will experience more heat waves well
they're becoming so frequent and intense
that the spanish city of seville became
the first to officially name and rank
its heat waves earlier this year and
projections suggest that southern europe
will get drier cities like athens in
greece are set to face more frequent and
intense droughts by 2050. well iggy
bassey is the founder and the ceo of the
climate intelligence service serviced
and he joins me now iggy good to see you
this evening
the the problem seems to be that cities
are being hard hit by significant
changes in their climate and the
infrastructures just can't cope
you're absolutely right uh the
infrastructure is aging and it's and if
you think about the design of the
infrastructure that fuels our cities it
never really be designed for these new
types of risks so
in sort of many ways the new risks are
out outperforming the engineering design
now that has pretty profound
implications for us the way we think
about our work the way we live um
the way we play the way we build new
infrastructure and also we have to think
about fairly large scale retrofitting of
our most critical infrastructure
across across europe so it's like 85
percent of people will be living in
cities i think it's about two-thirds
across the world by 2050. now what does
that mean for things like temperature
what does it mean for things like flood
defenses what does it mean for the nhs
for instance we actually i'm looking at
the nhs now to say what would be the
response times for things like heat
waves you just showed the um brief clips
of spain we can expect that across
multiple countries simultaneously
in the next couple of decades yeah i was
mentioning a couple of cities in my
introduction there iggy which cities
would you say are leading the way with
adaptation
i think it's hard because i think most
of the conversation to date has largely
been about net zero which is absolutely
necessary but there's been very little
discussion and very little um investment
within adaptation so
even if you just take the uk government
spend this year it's been dwarfed by net
zero versus adaptation i think there
should be some more funding available
from adaptation but city cities in the
sort of nordics have been pretty good at
start adapting i was just in helsinki
yesterday in fact
and i think they are making greater
investments in things like insulation
home pumps for instance so new forms of
energy so the faster we can mix our
energy within the cities i think the
better but we haven't seen any wide
scale adoption of of adaptation measures
frankly
and the other problem as well is that
we've got increased population pressure
expected in cities
you're right but that's also an
opportunity sam there's also an
opportunity to bring new technology to
city i mean you can amortize that
technology but as more and more people
are clustered together um i i think it's
a great opportunity to introduce
new technologies where things like
energy
things like so i think the challenge for
lots of green technology is that they
don't quite know where all that demand
will come from cities offers a great
opportunity to lower the cost very
quickly to drive drive adoption now that
does require some sort of public uh
private partnership as well because
these some of these technologies are
quite uncertain so it's incumbent upon
cities and there's been some great
movements um things like the c-40 for
instance where they have been
introducing new technologies pooling
their spending power together i think um
sadiq khan just last last week and about
a billion dollars worth of um zero
emission buses
sent to latin american cities for
instance so i think cities are not
waiting for central government they are
moving forward where they can
okay iggy bassey uh sounds like there
are some things to be hopeful about good
to talk to you this evening thank you
thank you
well do stay tuned because coming up
after the break i'll be joined by dame
julia king from the climate from the
committee on climate change and the
director of anti-poverty charity war on
want assad raymond we're going to be
discussing if fossil fuels are falling
out of favor and whether our energy
infrastructure is resilient what we were
just talking about there to withstand
the changing climate
i've teamed up with hp and the arbor day
foundation who last year planted a
million trees and this year plan to
plant a million more now a million trees
sounds like a huge amount but we need
more we're currently lagging way behind
europe 13 compared to 38
we need to up our game basically and we
need to start reforesting huge tracts of
land that um have been denuded of trees
over the years
we need to be very careful about the
type of trees that we plant ensuring
that it's native species learning from
our past mistakes but there are still
huge tracts of land
that can be
replanted reforested and that's why
i've teamed up with hp and arbor day to
try and encourage people to get behind
us if more businesses
would start thinking about the positive
effect that trees can have carbon
capture for our mental health
there are so many benefits that come
from them
it seems to me to be a very obvious
thing that that we could target now of
course there are many tree planting
campaigns and i'm sure lots of your
viewers will have heard uh
about tree planting initiatives over the
years but just imagine if every single
person in the uk started
um planting
10 20 30 trees we we would be making a
huge difference i've seen a growing tide
of people who really do feel passionate
about making a difference we're hearing
about all the negatives but here is
something that we can actually do with
our own hands we can actually make a
positive difference we can actually get
into the ground and start planting those
trees i can't reiterate enough that you
need to be careful about what kind of
trees you plant we don't want any
species
anywhere you need to think about the
biodiversity and um and using native
species but i think we need to go back
to that i think if if we could have a
big campaign where everyone got behind
it
i think it could be something that would
empower people and put a smile on
people's faces
hp who have got behind this campaign
have committed to plant three trees for
every comment left on the video on my
instagram account now this is one part
of their
forest positive initiative this is this
is about trying to become carbon neutral
and trying to empower people and give
people the opportunity to actually make
a difference
[Music]
i love my job because i get to do
something that is contributing to a
better future
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
early rain will clear eastern parts of
england on saturday morning to leave a
mix of sunny spells and showers some of
the showers will be heavy with hail
thunder and even some snow mainly over
the hills it will feel very cold with a
significant wind chill in the strong and
gusty winds
the showers will merge into longer
spells of rain sleet and hill snow
especially in eastern scotland and
northern england
the brisk winds and frequent showers
will help keep air pollution levels low
on saturday between 1 and 3 on the daily
air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing those
climate issues of the day that's with
the chair of the adaptation subcommittee
of the committee on climate change dame
julia king and the director of the
anti-poverty charity war on want assad
raymond good to see you both this
evening we are starting with the news
that we heard earlier in the programme
that shell has announced that it is
pulling out of the cambo oil field
project saying that the economic case
for investment was just not strong
enough campaigners have called it a
death blow for cambo as the project
continues to lose support so is this the
clearest sign yet that fossil fuels are
falling out of favor and come first to
you
dame julia 30
of the investment has been pulled out 70
of it though is still there is it really
a death blow
well i'm hoping it is i'm hoping other
people will see that shell have done the
economic analysis and that if we're on a
path to no more than two degrees and
ideally 1.5 degrees
this just won't be profitable and and
really you know once we see industry
recognizing these things aren't going to
be profitable as we move to net zero
then uh that's brilliant because that's
what will really drive change
and assad the shell says that this is an
economic decision do you think it is or
do you think it's political
well firstly i think it's a huge victory
for people power without the campaigners
we would not be in a situation where
shell was pulling out of this camper oil
field so of course the fight isn't won
the uk government can still approve the
oil field along with the countless
others that are in the pipeline but it
does give us hope and it shows us that
when citizens work together collectively
and put pressure on both these dirty
polluting companies as well as our
government we can begin to see an end to
fossil fuels sir because we've got to
remember what the climate scientists
have told us we have can have no new oil
gas or coal if we want to meet the 1.5
degree threshold which is critical to
prevent the runaway catastrophic climate
change that we are beginning to see all
over the world yeah that was the iea
report wasn't it and and dan julia uh
to you
if we accept that it is an economic
decision from shell what does it tell us
about the intentions of these big fossil
fuel companies is it the start of a big
shift
well i hope i hope that's what it's
showing us because we do need the skills
of these companies um we need their
skills for hydrogen production we need
their skills for carbon capture and
storage so if this is really the start
of of these of these
high carbon energy companies recognizing
that um that the economics have changed
and they've got to become green low
carbon energy companies then that's i
mean that's that's really brilliant
and that says it doesn't need it's it
doesn't matter whether governments say
we should support this or not if if the
companies have recognized the economics
of changes changed and that changes
their businesses then the change will
happen yeah it's interesting to watch
isn't it and aside of course all of
these big uh projects very capital
intensive they all need a lot of money
and what we learned in glasgow at cop26
is that 130 trillion dollars worth
assets under management committed to net
zero but that's only 40 of the world's
asset under management so 60
of those assets are still happy as far
as we understand to invest in fossil
fuel projects
absolutely and uh and they're continuing
to invest in and the irony being that
some of those who are claiming that
they're going to be investing in in
renewable or clean energy are at the
same time pouring billions and billions
into dirty energy but look fix you know
the economic case uh one of the ways to
change that economic case of course is
fixing our tax system the uk has got a
very generous tax system to dirty energy
companies companies like shell for
example paid no tax last year in the uk
um we know that governments are handing
over something like 11 million dollars
per minute to dirty energy companies in
subsidies where
we're in trade deals like the energy
treaty charter which locks us into
decades of fossil fuels and even has
this thing called uh a corporate courts
investigate dispute settlement courts
which allows companies to sue
governments if they take actions that
threaten their profits these are all the
enabling systems that governments allow
and create which allow these fossil fuel
companies to operate i mean so where
it's in a ridiculous situation at the
moment where the netherlands the dutch
government is being sued for billions
because their government has planned to
phase out coal power power stations and
it's estimated that some of these
polluting companies are threatening to
suit governments for up to nine trillion
dollars in the coming years so really
you know it's government regulation and
government intervention which changes
the economy right i said i'm going to
jump in there because i want to talk
about the second topic this evening
where thousands of people across the
north of england and scotland are still
without power that's a week on from
storm arwen and according to the energy
secretary quasi-quatting climate change
will make extreme weather events like
this all the more common it means that
the focus is once again on resilience
and how where we live needs to be uh
adapted to withstand the climate change
uh dame julia if we're going to have
these big electrification projects we
need an electricity uh infrastructure
which is sturdy and doesn't fall over
don't we
we absolutely do because um as we move
to net zero we change our fuel use quite
dramatically so at the moment about 15
of our energy comes from electricity uh
as we get towards net zero that will
move to 60 to 70 percent of our of our
energy coming from electricity so it
will be absolutely crucial um that our
electricity system is resilient because
when the electricity fails everything
will stop
and we know that that things like storm
are when are going to be coming more
common um as the climate continues to
change and of course it will continue to
change until we get to net zero and and
i said uh even on the eve of cop 26 we
saw the train lines uh let loads of us
down stranded us all um compared to
other global cities how are the cities
in the uk
uh faring do you think in terms of
infrastructure for that transition
so as uh iggy your previous guest was
saying look no no cities infrastructure
is fit for purpose when dealing with
this climate crisis and of course these
impacts are much deeper and happening
far worse in countries of the global
south we don't have the capacity of the
resources to be able to deal with them
but you take indonesia for example
they're now planning to move their city
jakarta their capital city we've seen
you know from dhaka to new york to
venice to bangkok all of these cities
under threat and it's not simply about
our energy infrastructure here in london
if you remember we had heavy rainfall
and our tube system
i'm sorry to jump in there assad we are
out of time dame julia king assad
raymond thank you very much indeed both
of you that is all from us for this week
but coming up on sky news tonight we'll
be answering all of your questions about
the omicron variant of covet 19. that's
with a panel of experts thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you